steve ballmer of microsoft formerly
microsoft is meting billions on LA
Clippers he's agreed to buy the team for
two billion dollars that's about ten
percent of his personal fortune of
almost 19 billion dollars that much that
much is a former of microsoft CEO
overpaying you think begs the question I
mean what are you really buying if
you're not getting the stadium if you're
not getting the TV deal you know you're
getting players you're getting a piece
of a monopoly this is so franchise
hilaria while franchises period in in
sports are not to be had for love or
money they don't come up for sale that
off right and so the chance to get just
one of them I mean I think actually
you're not getting the players you're
getting the name the Clippers in the NBA
franchise that alone is what I'll fall
of Em's the previous sale we there's no
way Paisley new liquid market there's no
way to value them strongly here that you
owe me the only air I'm gonna do Steve
Ballmer monologue monologue for you all
right this is what he's thinking right
this is what's going on in his brain you
all want it and you can't have it I got
it no one else can get a major sports
franchise in a big city okay that is the
Steve Ballmer I in her monologue Iraq
Mark Cuban would not do that down in
Dallas idle no no he would just her
eternal yeah and then hurl insults at so
maybe they'd have to abide retina so
it's almost like a sovereign he's almost
like a sovereign wealth fund trends yeah
but we long-term feel here we see this
happening in sports teams in Europe two
soccer teams are way overvalued and it's
because if you've got a lot of oil money
and you love the game there's they're
all there's a limited number of
franchises you can buy there's only one
Liverpool there's only insecure United
and that's why we're seeing such huge
sums just pouring into that game over
there it's the same reason over here
there's only two basketball teams in la
delivered imprint change la the LA
Clippers from the osso ran team to the
number one team yes my good he's gonna
invest in them may I mean maybe Haiti
maybe he'll drop five billion on a
stadium who knows I mean the Clippers
were notoriously cheap indeed anyone his
own stadium I don't think a small item
here is what he has been through at
Microsoft right north he gets now to
hang out with cool people I mean part of
sports is you instantly yeah your
guarantee on Henry there as a hedge fund
guy
doing brilliant work I won't bore you
with the technicals now of mr. Henry's
accomplished been investing but
essentially dual a large part of the
world he was unknown until he bought a
small baseball team in Boston you know
that changed things yeah